my name is Martin Hagan I'm very happy
to welcome you to the fourth and final
of our Frankie lectures
which are being held in conjunction with
seminar on how us being in time so for
those of you have not heard this before
I do want to mention that one of the
great things about the format of the
Frankie seminars is that you're allowed
to invite distinguished guests who not
only come and give a lecture as
Professor Steven Carol would do for us
now but who also really spend a whole
day here engaged in philosophical
reflection and discussion and as I
thought would be the case not very happy
to report has been the case
faceting cow has been a wonderful
presence today here already engaging in
that philosophical activity of asking
for and giving reasons that he has spent
much time reflecting on his own views of
the writing so it's wonderful to see
that commitment practiced and not just
theorized so that's been truly wonderful
and steam crowley is one of the leading
interpreters of Heidegger and especially
already hiding a being in time and one
of his great contributions is precisely
to bring issues of rationality
normativity recent giving to bear on a
book such as being in time where like
several dominant ways of reading this
book comes in that's very resistant to
that sort of discourse and as a Crowell
instead wants to show how they're great
resources for how to go not for
rejecting reason but for rethinking what
the dynamic of Reason is what
excellencies the challenges of engaging
in and being committed to asking for and
giving reasons or that's allowed him to
put highly were in conversation with
many of the most exciting contemporary
conversations in philosophy also related
to other people we've had here this
semester such as Robert Pittman Robert
Bandhan so it all makes great sense
he's the author of two books of his own
the first who still Heidegger in a space
of meaning passed towards trans mental
terminology and that most recently
normativity and phenomenology and who
stole and Heidegger
which is really a treasure trove of
great chapters on both hosted on
Heidegger that can be read read on their
own but also form a very compelling
whole so I really recommend that book he
is the Joseph and Joanna Nash through
Mullen professor
philosophy at Rice University and we are
extremely delighted to have him here
have the chance to listen to and learn
from him today so please join me in
welcoming I I need to begin with a word
of apology and then a word of thanks the
apology is that as you can hear I'm two
weeks into a cold that having trouble
shaking so my voice will be going in and
out the words of thanks are due to
Martin Haglund for the invitation to
return to Yale and meet with the
students of whom I was once one and it
brings back a lot of memories and Jensen
Souter for handling all the details of
this visit it's been a delight my family
goes back into these parts for a long
ways and I don't get up here that often
from Houston so every time I do I really
appreciate it and to show my
appreciation I'm going to deliver a
rather self-indulgent paper and I hope
you'll forgive me for that it's called
methodological atheism an essay in
second person phenomenology and I begin
in honor of the translation of the final
volume of nose guards great work my
struggle which is I haven't read a word
of it by the way but I do like the title
so that's my section one is my struggle
today I want to explore the high
daguerreian idea that commitment is
necessary for intentionality that is for
experiencing something as something
understanding commitment requires a dip
into second person phenomenology that is
experiencing oneself as the addressee of
a normative claim I will argue that the
second person phenomenology of
commitment precludes identifying the a
dresser of the claim and so entails
methodological atheism put otherwise
while identifying an a dresser is an
option doing so is an intentional act
and so already presupposes commitment as
I see it methodological atheism is what
binds philosophy to the human condition
and so also to humanistic inquiry as
distinct from science theory and
worldview since phenomenology is central
to my argument it would behoove me to
explain what it is as this would leave
me no time for the argument itself
however I will indulge in a few
autobiographical remarks that may
suggest why I think phenomenological
reflection is philosophically necessary
phenomenological philosophy can be
understood as a twist on Aristotle's
idea of first philosophy as the attempt
to specify what philosophical inquiry
inquires into as an undergraduate I was
absorbed by this irritating meta
question since it seemed to me that
everything in the world had already been
parceled out to other fields of inquiry
eventually I learned that two answers in
historical sequence had been given
metaphysics and epistemology metaphysics
inquires into being not this or that
entity but the being of entities however
Aristotelian metaphysics involves an
ambiguity the being of entities is
identified with an entity whole fails
but also with some basic basic feature
of entities the categories are forms
that make a thing what it is
epistemology in contrast following Conte
takes our knowledge of entities to be
philosophies theme but here the
categorical conditions of possibility of
knowledge seemed either nothing but
cognitive processes studied by
psychology or else a new version of
metaphysics Hegel's apps
concept I was at a loss in this
situation the phenomenology of hood and
Heidegger appealed to me for them
philosophy thematize --is meaning is in
our experience of something as something
such meaning is presupposed in both
metaphysics and epistemology that is in
any discussion of entities or our
knowledge of them this idea was also
congenial since it's linked philosophy
tightly to other humanistic disciplines
concerned with meaning when I arrived at
Yale as a graduate student in the
mid-1970s the philosophy department was
like most philosophy departments in the
United States in thrall to the
philosophy of language the ubiquity of
courses on philosophy of mind and the
resurgence of metaphysics were far in
the future in one sense this was a boon
since language and meaning are obviously
deeply implicated but two things gave me
pause first meaning was understood
mainly in terms of frege's in midi tuned
I add the sense and reference of terms
and sentences viewed as material for
logical syntactic sand semantics yes
there was the later Vidkun Stein's idea
of seeing as but there was also his idea
that philosophical questions are at
bottom grammatical ones which seemed
quite alien to me second and more
troublingly
this was the heyday of Klein's two
dogmas which jettisoned meaning
altogether just old-fashioned
metaphysical essence wedded to the word
in favor of a naturalistic pragmatism to
my worried mind this again seemed to
leave philosophy with nothing to do the
under labourer conception held no appeal
and so there was little recourse but
pursue the phenomenological path where
linguistic meaning a kind of intentional
experience shows up in a reflection on
the correlation between intentional acts
and intentional contents at the time
Yale was also home to Derry das
challenge to phenomenology his
deconstruction of the metaphysics of
presence upon which phenomenology
supposedly staked its
on this view phenomenology z' approach
to meaning is compromised by its
foundationalism while intentional
experience is temporal and so our
engagement with entities has an
anticipatory or merely presumptive sense
clozaril held that our consciousness of
such things gives itself with a kind of
evidence that renders epistemic doubts
about it Oh Dios Derrida challenged this
presence to self in the name of
deference the spacing that belongs to
time and renders such self presence
impossible as Martin Hegel and puts the
this point quote in spite of whose rules
assertions the structure of retention
consciousness cannot be essentially
different from the structure of
representation representation if the
meaning at issue in the intentional
correlation is not epistemic Lee secured
through the evidence of reflection then
meaning or the as is always in play
undecidable and phenomenological
philosophy appears to be a literary art
Derrida's critique of phenomenology
extended to Heidegger superficially very
different version inquiry into the being
of beings
despite Heidegger's epistemic anti
foundationalism Derrida sensed nostalgia
for an ultimate meaning or truth of
being that would eliminate the ambiguity
in Aristotelian Anto theology to me this
criticism told against the later
Heidegger but a too quickly dismissed
heidegger's phenomenological account of
designs understanding of being
specifically it did not fully appreciate
the methodological atheism entailed by
Heidegger's approach to the meaning of
being what then is methodological
atheism section 2 methodological atheism
and the phenomenological project
distinguishing heidegger's phenomenology
from whose rules and shielding it from
both naturalistic and deconstructive
suspicions about meaning is its embrace
of second person
phenomenology a what he calls
fundamental ethics evident in the
categorical structure of commitment yet
fundamental ethics is itself informed by
a commitment Heidegger shares with us
role a commitment to metaphysical
neutrality for both phenomenology
thematize --is meaning or intentionality
and so suspends concern with the
entities and their properties remains
neutral with regard to the questions of
fact at issue in our various everyday
and scientific practices because
philosophy has no independent source of
cognitive insight into such things the
project of phenomenological philosophy
entails methodological atheism Heidegger
highlights this point in a lecture
course from 1925 while taking a stand on
the ambiguity in Aristotelian
metaphysics having defined phenomenology
as categorical intuition or the
analytical description of intentionality
in its a priori he writes quote as long
as phenomenology understands itself it
will adhere to this course of
investigation against any sort of profit
ism within philosophy and against any
inclination to provide guidelines for
life philosophical research is and
remains atheism which is why philosophy
can allow itself the arrogance of
thinking if anybody knows where this
quote the arrogance of thinking comes
from I would appreciate the reference I
thought it was Nietzsche but I can't
find it
for now I note only two points about
this passage first the atheism in
question is methodological because it
follows from phenomenology commitment to
neutrality its unconcerned with the
existence of the entities whose
givenness being or meaning it Dymatize
'as for Heidegger phenomenology is the
true ground he says for research into
the categories it is transcendental
inquiry into the being of beings this
means that the other side of
Aristotelian metaphysics inquiry into
the highest entity or Hotei OS is not a
proper topic for philosophy
such inquiry can of course be undertaken
perhaps in theology on the basis of a
canonical tradition perhaps even
scientifically or comparatively but it
presupposes high-tier thinks a
phenomenology of religious life the
categorical structure of which is the
concern of phenomenological reflection
this point is not limited to theology of
course introducing the passage just
sighted Heidegger criticizes misrule for
failing to distinguish adequately
between phenomenology and descriptive
psychology the study of consciousness as
an entity descriptive psychology to
understand phenomenology as psychology
is to take the latter's categories as
authoritative and this too is a form of
theism as is any appeal to authoritative
entities or Sciences including the
sciences of life this idea under writes
heidegger's claim that philosophy must
avoid profit ISM the goal of providing
guidelines for life these phrases are
drawn from Heidegger's debate with veldt
on shaolin philosophy the project of
constructing action guiding pictures of
the meaning of life by speculatively
extending the findings of the natural
social and Human Sciences to their
asymptotic point of unification
this too is theological since it helps
itself to contingent premises about the
way things actually are but what's the
point of philosophy if it refuses to
pronounce on how we ought to live this
brings us to the second point of
interest in the passage namely
Heidegger's claim that methodological
atheism allows philosophy the arrogance
of thinking here arrogance might be
understood as autonomy philosophy is its
own thing and need not take dictation
from other cultural forms such as
science or religion however one might
also understand arrogance as irrigation
ceasing expropriating usurping or
assuming which suggests that such
thinking presumptively appropriates for
itself something that is not its own
treating it as as though it were
methodological atheism on this view we
serve to conceal philosophies theft of
something to which it has no right
passing itself off as autonomous though
it lives from the exploitation of its
other this was a manual levy gnosis take
on the phenomenological project for levy
nos two phenomenological philosophy is
essentially atheism to think about the
intentional structure of meaning
requires that that the thinker exercise
a kind of freedom that can close itself
off to the claims of the world as he
says all the way to atheism but such
ontological irrigation is only the first
step since 411 Oz meaning is sustained
by a forgotten condition that exceeds
freedom and Chasen's thinking arrogant
presumption of reducing everything other
to intentional content that Venus names
this condition the face of the other the
face is an interdict reclaim on freedom
that escapes intentional correlation and
so also the ontological categories that
shape it introduction is his version of
fundamental ethics grounded neither in
reason nor in an ontology of the good it
is worth noting than in a reversal of
Heidegger's decision concerning the
ambiguity of Aristotelian metaphysics
Levinas calls ethics first philosophy he
means that categorical inquiry into the
being of entities depends on an avowal
of an authoritative command ho theos
that shatters the arrogance of thinking
less colorfully phenomenology lives from
a metaphysical condition that cannot be
recognized under the constraints of its
methodologically atheist approach to
intentionality here we get a glimpse of
second person phenomenology since lemme
nasus argument turns on a normative
claim made on the thinker which situates
her as au accusative the face of the
other is not grasped cognitively in
perception but as what quote calls my
freedom into question and this
experience of being called into question
is the theme of second person
phenomenology
yeah by way of orientation consider what
distinguishes Levinas second person
phenomenology from Stephen der waals
exemplary analysis of the second person
to standpoint namely his objection to
DAR walls argument that being morally
called into question presupposes the
normative Felicity condition of
symmetrical Authority between a dresser
and a dressy Ford our wall such symmetry
is necessary if the others claim on me
is to be valid for levy notes however
the experience of acknowledging the
claim is basic and so prior to the
question of validity the others command
first inducts me into normative space
the space of meaning where symmetrical
rights and obligations can be can be
negotiated and are negotiated without
end
such negotiation can be summed up in
dari das claim that justice is not d
constructible however i shall say no
more about questions of validity
justification and the political since i
want to focus on the prior issue of
whether second person phenomenology
requires as both Derrida and Lebanon in
different ways insist a break with
ontology the methodological II atheist
phenomenology of meaning I will argue
that it does not put positively the
second person character of Heidegger's
phenomenology of commitment remains
atheistic and so preserves the arrogance
or the autonomy of thinking I will frame
the argument by excuse me I will frame
the argument by idiosyncratically
appropriating the distinction found in
the analytic literature between a
normativity first account of reasons and
a reasons first account of normativity
concept excisions first approach moral
norms are normative that is valid or
binding because they are grounded in
pure practical reason
levy gnosis fundamental ethics in
contrast exemplifies a normativity first
approach reasons and rationality are
possible for us living beings only when
we have knowledge acknowledged a
normative check on our freedom who Cyril
like Kant adopts a reasons first account
of the normativity constitutive of all
intentional content while Heidegger's
phenomenology of commitment follows a
normativity first path unlike levy
gnosis metaphysical version however
Heidegger's remains methodologically
atheist and so has affinities with dar
walls reasons first approach
understanding commitment then requires
that we consider the difference between
dar wall and Lebanon in somewhat more
detail so section 3 I if take up dar
walls reasons first approach to second
person phenomenology according to Darwin
second person reasons are valid valid
normative claims that we make on one
another's conduct and will and his
question is this what interpersonal
conditions must be in place in order for
second person reasons to exist as a
first approximation he writes quote what
makes a second person what makes a
reason second personal is that it is
grounded in day Ouray
authority relations that an address or
hole takes to hold between him and his
addressee end quote
second person reasons thus depend on the
presupposition that you have the
authority to command my will what can
give you that authority Darwin's
analysis is the second persons
standpoint is meant to our answer this
question quite generally the others
normative claim on me can yield a valid
second person reason only if the other
and I share quote a common second
personal Authority competence and
responsibility simply as free and
rational agents the authority to issue
binding commands then and to hold
someone accountable for carrying them
out must be shared
the demand for symmetrical Authority
arises from Darwin's focus on the
validity of second-person reasons if
there are second valid second-person
reasons then certain normative Felicity
conditions must obtain absent such
conditions a command lacks the power to
constitute a valid agent relative reason
for me to act but even if this is true
it does not rule out that a command
could have other kinds of power other
ways of binding Darwin identifies one
such case namely coercion the command
that rests on some non normative power
but are all asymmetrical commands
instances of coercion and if not might
such a command be a condition for our
ability to entertain
second-person reasons lemme nasus
phenomenology purports to identify a
command that is both normative and
asymmetrical one that constitutes a
condition on our taking up the second
person standpoint and more generally
clarifies how we become attuned to the
normative force of reasons second person
or otherwise since Lebanon says view
involves a distinction between second
person phenomenology and the second
person's standpoint I will consider two
phenomena logically telling aspects of
the latter its holism and its character
as a performative attitude second person
reasons are agent relative they can
appear only to one who occupies what
Jurgen Habermas calls the performative
act quote the performative attitude of a
person taking part in interaction my
indignation at being trod upon differs
from anger at your being the cause of my
pain because indignation includes
consciousness of quote the violation of
an underlying normative expectation that
is valid and quote not just for the two
of us but ultimately for all competent
actors and such consciousness is
possible only within the second person
standpoint quote the perspective one
assumes in addressing practical thought
or speech - or acknowledging address
from another that this is a performative
attitude as indicated by two phenomena
logical features first and this is
Darwin's quote the second person stance
is a version of the first person
standpoint and quote that is a version
of the eyes performative character which
Darwin explicates in terms of fish's
notion of self positing second quote
what the second person stance excludes
is the third person perspective and
quote where one regards one's self agent
neutrally rather than the a dresser or
addressee of a normative claim this
illuminates the holistic nature of the
second person's standpoint the
performance in question may be conceived
as a move in a game whose rules are
already in place and to engage in which
one must be second person competent what
makes the second person standpoint
game-like is the fact as Darwell points
out that it consists of an inter
definable circle of roles a dresser
dressy skills competence in standing
Authority each of which implies all the
rest and can be justified only within
the circle the idea that second person
reasons entails symmetrical relations of
authority thus arises within the circle
of concepts because these concepts
define the kind of entity who can play
the game namely persons and if as he
said Darwin says the very concept of
person is itself a second person concept
the essential features of personhood are
also defined free and rational I cannot
have a second person reason to do
something if my will is responsive only
to causes or two motives that have no
normative force that is I must be free
nor can I have such reasons as opposed
to there being reasons for me to do
something unless I can be moved by
reasons as reasons that is I must be
rational thus whether I issue a claim or
in the recipient of one the capacities
that matter are shared between a dresser
and addressee the claim succeeds in
providing a second
and reason only because the roles of a
dresser and addressee are defined by a
standing that both share the authority
to address second person claims in this
notion of authority we can recognize
both the reasons first character of dar
walls argument for the necessary
symmetry between players and also his
commitment to methodological atheism
second personal reasons exist only from
the standpoint from the second person
standpoint in which I am either the a
dresser or the addressee of a normative
claim the roles are symmetrical because
we must presuppose quote that those we
address can guide themselves by a
reciprocal recognition of the second
personal reasons we address and our
authority to address them end quote
thus the normativity of a claim derives
from its rationality and its authority
presupposes a recognition of the
autonomy of both a dresser and addressee
as in Heidegger this condition brings
methodological atheism in its Train
Darwell elucidates the claim that I just
went through Darwell elucidates his
claim with what he calls fitness point
quote we can be held morally responsible
only for what we can hold ourselves
responsible for by making moral demands
of ourselves from the perspective of one
free and rational agent among others if
that is so the symmetrical authority of
a dresser and addressee belongs to the
game because rational beings are
interchangeable a rational being cannot
demand of another rational being
anything that the latter could not
demand of herself I am NOT accountable
to another for anything that I cannot
demand myself Darwell reinforces FIFA's
point by considering Samuel pouf
endorsed take on theological
volunteerism though on the volunteers
dick picture quote moral obligations are
all ultimately owed to God and quote
poof endorsed point is that an
obligation can arise quote only if God
addresses us as rational agents God can
hold us responsible only if God can
assume that we
can quote hold ourselves responsible in
our own reasoning and thought end quote
otherwise the command could only move us
by fear of sanctions that might coerce
compliance but dar wall goes further
claiming that quote holding ourselves
responsible in our own reasoning and
thought requires that we must be able to
take up a second person standpoint on
ourselves and hold ourselves accountable
from that point of view but why should
this be why can I not hold myself
accountable for something say an
obligation to help those in need without
seeing myself as belonging to a
community of free and rational beings if
being able to take up a second person
standpoint on myself simply means that
it is possible for me to do so this does
not mean that a normative command say
gods can reach me only if I do take up
such a standpoint goofin door folds that
quote each agent forms a moral community
with God alone with God being
accountable to no one
end quote thus it might be true that one
can form such a community with God only
if one can hold oneself accountable to
oneself before God and it might also be
true that quote one will have this
capacity only if one is also capable of
entering into a community of mutually
accountable persons end quote but does
not seem to follow that entering into a
moral community with God alone requires
that one actually consider oneself from
the second person standpoint it could be
that the moral community with God makes
taking up the second person standpoint
on oneself possible the alternative
would be to say that God's command can
obligate me only if I stand in a second
person relation of symmetrical authority
with God such of you does away with
moral asymmetry to be sure but it also
does away with God which seems to be
Darwin's point the presuppositional
analysis of the second person standpoint
is methodological II atheist
it can acknowledge no gods no persons
with an asymmetrical authority to issue
valid commands but this does not mean
that there can be no God's at all
a dressers of a command for which I hold
myself responsible without presupposing
that I have reciprocal authority to
command such gods in turn since this is
a phenomenological point it is not
constrained by the presuppositions of
the second person standpoint Darwell
himself acknowledges this distinction
while his analysis primarily concerned
with the performative commitments of
persons as players in the game of giving
and asking for reasons he also
recognizes the limited scope of the game
it is something that we assume or enter
into the second person standpoint is
neither exhaustive of our lives hence of
our phenomenology nor automatic somehow
out of a wider field of experience
it requires uptake there's nothing
necessary about the game or rather if
there is a certain necessity to it that
necessity must lie outside the game lest
the latter prove only a game quote no
more than rational rationally optional
or worse illusory if the second person
standpoint is a practice into which we
must be inaugurated this entry move can
be understood in two ways on the one
hand we can approach it as dar wall and
Habermas do in terms of developmental
psychology and the history of moral
enlightenment on the other hand we can
approach it phenomenologically as levy
NOS and Heidegger do through in a
reflection on experiences that make up
take of the second person standpoint
category lis intelligible such
phenomenology need take no issue with
dar walls reasons first approach to the
necessary conditions for valid second
person reasons but if levy nos is right
that the second person standpoint
originates in an experience of
obligation that constitutes of being as
rational notions like freedom and
rationality must also be understood in a
normativity first way dar wall regularly
the appeal appeals to phenomenological
evidence that is two descriptions that
are
cover what is essential to the meaning
constituted in various kinds of
experience for instance to say that the
second person standpoint is a
performative attitude means that I
experience claims as normative and do
not merely consider them understood
phenomenologically the presuppositions
of such an attitude are the intentional
implications or horizons of second
person practices which make the meaning
experienced in such practices what it is
for the the agent so engaged and if the
agent the person is constituted by
engaging in second person practices then
the person phenomenologically considered
must be intelligible to herself as the
one whose life be it otherwise what it
may is normatively at stake in what she
is doing
the primary phenomenological evidence
Darwell draws upon however is a
description of reactive attitudes such
attitudes for instance indignation that
someone has stepped on my toe or
resentment at the absence of an apology
intentionally imply the experience of
the violation of a normative claim that
I expect the other to acknowledge
because I too have the authority to make
such a claim an authority which the
other must acknowledge because it
belongs to us as free and rational
agents of course reactive attitudes do
not exhaust moral phenomenology but by
focusing on them Darwin's approach
foregrounds cases in what in which I
make claims on another we might wonder
however whether reactive attitudes must
move in this self to other direction
here levy NASA's moral phenomenology
proves instructive section 4 lemme nasus
normativity first approach to second
person phenomenology for lemme nasus the
experience of being commanded is the
experience of an interdiction on a
freedom that I already possess freedom
is the living beings power to remain the
same in interacting with its environment
paradigmatically
by assimilating that
in the form of nourishment such freedom
is not defined in terms of rational
self-determination and includes nothing
normative in its exercise the
interdiction on such freedom the command
thou shalt not kill is the inception of
the normative the feeling of obligation
because I thus initially appear as you
accusative lemme nasus phenomenology is
second personal but it is not an
instance of the second person standpoint
while the living being can assimilate
everything other to itself through
alimentation labor and conceptual
comprehension I'm just going through
levy gnosis view here the address er the
capital o other is experienced as
resisting such assimilation by its
height the metaphor of height means that
this experience is normative but the
normativity involved is not mediated by
a presupposition of symmetry quote I you
these are not individuals of a common
concept
he says if that is so then I cannot
initially claim an equal status to
command the other based on a shared set
of characteristics being free and
rational or being conspecifics
and so I cannot exchange places with the
a dresser in my singularity I do not
have any resources for making normative
claims I learn what the normative is
through the others command as levan us
expresses it the others command is
teaching and experience of something
that could not in principle be my
ethically drawn out of the living beings
freedom we are thus returned to a
version of theological volunteerism but
lemme nasus account does not conform to
proof endorsed point namely that for
God's command to constitute an
obligation it must be addressed to me as
free and rational being lemme nasus
argues that it is through the uptake of
the command that I become a being whose
freedom is rational but it might
initially appear that the asymmetry
between a dresser and addressee
means that my uptake of the command can
be based only on asymmetrical power
relations the fear of sanctions for
evidence however the command is the end
of powers these are quotes if the
freedom that characterizes life is
grounded in the experience of the I can
my power to appropriate the world then
the interdict on such experience
transforms my factual power into
normative powerlessness the interdict is
not a violent imposition on my freedom
but attests to the impotence of violence
if I hear the command experience the
other as a height I can still exercise
my murderous freedom but I do not
thereby eliminate the obligation not to
kill
this is just what normative binding
amounts to even if I violate the command
I'm still bound by it the experience of
this powerlessness initiates me into
normative space it might still appear
that I could only be coerced into
acknowledging the binding character of
the command what other motive do I have
for acknowledging the others Authority
in addressing this question lemme nasus
second person phenomenology diverges
radically from Darwin's account of the
second person standpoint for unlike
proven dorks God the other has neither
the authority to command nor sanctions
to impose the command rests on nothing
but itself it is he says the first word
how then is the attitude in which I hear
the command react to it take it up to be
described phenomenologically levy nos
names this attitude desire a reactive
attitude that does not address a claim
to the other but acknowledges a claim
received from the other as a reactive
attitude desire cannot be understood in
terms of pro attitudes toward things
that will satisfy the various hungers
that beset the living being such things
are of course goods and give the living
being reasons
to pursue them but the living being does
not pursue them as its reasons it has
them but does not act on them as reasons
desire in contrast embraces the ethical
resistance to life's freedom which quote
liberates freedom from the arbitrary by
calling frame into question the
interdict does not limit but promotes by
freedom by arousing goodness opening
another path another standard by which
freedom can measure itself as in Plato
then maybe nación desire aims beyond
being beyond the wants and needs of the
living being toward the edia to desired
freedom recognizes its moral vocation
and while
[Music]
the shame the freedom feels for itself
end quote
this and nothing else is the phenomenon
of welcoming the other yet as we have
seen shame does not a base freedom but
elevates it introducing freedom into the
pasta to the possibility of measuring
itself against what is better than being
the dimension of the ideal that arises
with my desire for goodness this may
sound arcane but such ideality form a
form of normativity is ubiquitous in our
intentional life it is a condition on
meaning on encountering something as
something clozaril for instance
describes how any current perceptual
experience is pervaded by normative
anticipation of what subsequent
perceptions must reveal if the current
perception is veridical that is if the
perceived thing is as it is taken to be
without such normative anticipation
further experience could not confirm or
disconfirm my current one but could only
replace it with another
Heidegger expands this analysis of
perceptual meaning and arrives with
Lebanon at the ethical ground of reason
the second personal phenomenon of
conscience beginning with our practical
engagement in the world
Heidegger argues that things can show up
meaningfully that is as what they are
hammers nails lumber only if I'm
sensitive to that their suitability for
the task suitability a normative notion
is relative to what I'm trying to do
with them say make a birdhouse whether a
certain hammer is good or bad for the
job is determined by what a birdhouse is
ideally supposed to be but what
determines what I'm trying to do
Heidegger denies that appeal to what
Searle calls intention in action is
enough since such intentions depend on
that for the sake of which I am doing
what I'm doing that is on what I'm
trying to be following course guard we
make all this by practical identity for
instance if I'm acting for the sake of
being a carpenter if being a carpenter
is my practical identity then my
technical manipulation of tools and
materials that eventuates in a leaky box
with large nails sticking out will be
judged a failure but if I'm acting for
the sake of being an artist in the style
of art Povera the very same
manipulations with the same result may
be judged a great success the
phenomenological point is that things do
not possess their ID allottee in
themselves for Heidegger it comes to
them from my commitment by caring about
whether I succeed or fail at at what it
is or means to be whatever it is that
I'm trying to be in being committed to
teaching for instance what it means to
be a teacher is at issue that is I
measure myself against the good in
respect of teaching while this measure
is initially found in the norms of
teaching that belong to my historical
community such norms provide no recipes
they are themselves at issue in my
commitment to teaching acting in their
light I take a stand on what they should
be and so what I do is exemplary of what
I take teaching to mean commitment is
less oriented toward a good beyond being
and only if I'm committed that is bind
myself to the measure care about
succeeding or failing at what I'm trying
to be can I encounter things as
succeeding or failing at what that being
what they are supposed to be this in a
nutshell is the argument for the first
claim I introduced at the outset
commitment is a necessary condition on
intentionality and meaning
commitment is neither a function of my
rationality nor of my animal life no
horse is committed to being horse nor
can I could be committed to being alive
I just am alive and I can try to stay
that way for Heidegger committment
belongs to the performative character of
my being the being who can say I is
neither a natural substance nor a
rational subject but a being quote in
whose being that very being is an issue
for it this is a phenomenological point
whose evidence lies in an experience
that teaches me Who I am
the call of conscience for leve NOS as
we saw conscience is a second personal
phenomenon can the same be said for
Heidegger for leve NOS consciousness
conscience is the shame freedom feels
for itself precisely as freedom and so
is not tied to anything I have done for
Heidegger to the call of conscience
neither warns nor approves and does not
invoke any antecedent law or aught those
are quotes while it does give me to
understand my guilt fooled this
understanding is independent of any
practical identity but just for this
reason the call might seem to lack the
character of a command and so also the
normative force that levy NOS takes to
belong to the command as our K or
principle indeed it might well appear
that high daguerreian conscience is not
a second person phenomenon at all but
this appearance is deceiving first the
call guilty does have the structure of a
command highlighting the connection
between schuldig and Fairmont Fort Lee
Heidegger interprets the call to mean
that I am responsible for taking over
being a ground goon sign uber named as
throne I am delivered over two grounds
over which I have no power the non
normative causes and inclinations that
move the living being but since my being
is precisely at issue I stand before
such fact ik grounds as before a choice
I'm unable to choose the inclinations or
motivations I have
but neither do they necessitate what I
do in conscience I learned that I must
take over that is assume the status of
being a ground since the call reaches
the sort of entity who can be only
performative Lee this must is
experienced in the you accusative you
must take over being a ground if design
is originally the addressee of a command
then we stand before two final questions
what is the phenomenological meaning of
being a ground or commitment and who
commands Heidegger's answer shows that
despite the calls independence from any
prevailing law or ought it is normative
in Levy no sense being a ground cannot
mean that I'm the absolute foundation of
myself since I find myself already
inclined in various ways I never have
power over my being from the ground up
as high-tier says further taking over
being a ground assuming the status of a
ground cannot simply be to acknowledge
what inclines me inclinations need no
such acknowledgement instead it is to
possible eyes them another term from
Heidegger to consider them not only for
what they are but in light of what is
best in regard to what I'm committed to
being in conscience as Heidegger
explains in foam hazing disk run this
that you must direct me beyond being
toward the idea of the good idea to
Agatha thus quote to be a ground is to
consider the Givens of my situation in
normative light to consider whether
their claims ought to be embraced or
rejected as my reasons if that is so
then my response to the call commitment
has the phenomenological structure of
levy na Sein desire for goodness I take
responsibility for the good or meaning
at issue in what I am trying to be that
is for the normative force of the
reasons for which I act thus conscience
the call to take over being ground is
the phenomenological or
justification accounting for myself by
way of reasons if to take over being a
ground is to treat my wants and needs in
light of what is best
that is as potentially justifying
reasons then my response to the call is
apologia
responsibility for reasons is answer
ability to others for what I take to be
best as in levy nos then reason is
originally reason giving but even if we
can understand the call of conscience as
a command that introduces me to
normative space and so makes the space
of reasons and intentionality possible
is it really a second person phenomenon
who is the a dresser
Heidegger specifically denies that the
it who calls is someone else who is with
me in the world and he goes so far as to
say that quote the impossibility of
making the caller more definite is a
positive feature of the call finally he
describes the call as coming from me yet
from beyond me dare roof house me rental
uber me in this passage from me means
that the call belongs phenomenologically
to the first person I myself from beyond
me in turn signifies that the mode of
the first person at issue is the you
accusative being an addressee the call
addresses me in a way that exceeds all
my projects my practical identities and
so exceeds whatever self
I have performative Lee achieved we
might charitably interpret this beyond
as the normative height lemme nasus
attributes to the face of the other
however Heidegger also claims that quote
the caller is design itself in its
uncanny nosov
can we accept this identification of the
a dresser as I myself thereby removing
conscience from the field of second
person phenomenology on phenomenological
grounds I think we must hold fast to the
second personal character of the call
and following Heidegger zone insistence
on the impossibility of making the
caller more definite understand the
phenomenon of conscience
as attesting to the fact that second
person phenomenology must remain
methodologically atheist neutral with
regard to the a dresser it thereby loses
nothing of its command character or its
normativity what is essential to the
call is experiencing myself as you
accusative and naming the a dresser will
be a subsequent intentional act that
already rests on my commitment this was
the second claim I promised to address
at the outset of course much more needs
to be said but since I've gone on too
long already allow me to conclude by
circling back to dairy doc in his
elaborate meditations on Kierkegaard
levy Nos and Heidegger in the gift of
death Derrida arrives at the issue that
concerns us quote well as soon as this
quote as soon as a structure of
conscience exists that is as soon as I
have within me thanks to the invisible
word as such a witness that others
cannot see and who is at the same time
other than me and more intimate with me
than myself then there is what I call
God there is what I call God in me it
happens that I call myself God a phrase
that is difficult to distinguish from
God calls me for it is on such a
condition that I can call myself or be
called in secret this I take it is an
etched phenomenological description the
call that informs my commitment my being
aground brings methodological atheism
with it since any intentional act in
which I identify the address ER will be
secretly a pyretic to say that God calls
me is to call myself God
[Applause]
I'm happy to take questions or brickbats
tomatoes whatever if you have any
Stephen mr. flan then unless I could
address by another face of the other I
can't have this learners or I can't have
desires for certain content or yeah he
distinguishes sharply between desires
and needs and he needs our satisfaction
to relax something I'm hungry or
whatever so he we talked about that that
is a desire for food but he calls me and
what what characterizes desire is the
suspension of that need and an
orientation toward the good so in other
words when I'm when I recognize that
this wanton freedom so to speak has been
restricted to this way through this
introduced the command that I think
normative freedom is set off in another
direction the name of which he calls
desire and he correlates that with the
kind of good that he's using tonic
languages beyond being it's what things
should be thought and he claimed is that
that it's this kind of desire responding
to a restriction on life needs that
introduces me
or to see the sunset or whatever it
might be and it's hard to see how any
state like that requires the address
what you've got is well it's not just
any old this desire that one beat could
I be good
so is the thought that it does actually
seem to be intuitive that well obviously
this difference between czar ordinary
desires
experiences or for certain states where
it is and wanted to be good better
oneself that requires some notion a
different sort of scale still like let's
see why that would require well I guess
we could go back to take a walk
I guess his thought is trying to think
my way it seems to be that there's a
difference between the way animals move
they move as a word to satisfy the need
and when we take a walk there's more
than that and so that correlate the more
the higher calls it the more and being
it's the meaning we can't get away from
things meaning something to us take a
walk and it's part of something I'm
trying to be so and it's only it's not
to mention that he's trying to capture I
think that difference if if we if we
just focus on walking as moving
somewhere then right or satisfying an
itch to walk then that would be
on the inside but if maybe this is
stipulative just claiming that there is
this attribute of us its capacity that
we have that I'm going to call the
desire to make tracks in the world
somehow and it's introducing us into
that hot illogical space is that we
determine news is something that he
thinks is not possible without this kind
of normative restriction that's the
basic argument that goes back to me that
if that teaches people gives you that
teaches me something this idea of shame
for freedom as freedom as it had been
introduced and that call that the realm
of being of what is introduces me to
something that is other
[Music]
well that certain Department I mean I
think that her point about commits an
intentionality I want to be a good
Walker yeah I want to do walking in an
Eric Saade way right now that Efendi
excellent which means that I'm conscious
of a standard between a normative
standard distinguishes between good and
bad
just think about philosophical status of
the quasi developmental story that lemme
nasus tells yes you know you might think
it can't there's a there's a moral
pedagogy we have to learn to develop our
capacity for practical reason but it's a
that's a kind of like empirical story
and we don't need it potentially to tell
the story about the British and American
factories imminent inclination but it's
really important for loving us it seems
that something interrupts me and there's
I mean I don't notice a temporal
progression but there's something like
your before and after and certainly
whatever the other teaches me through
that relation is something I couldn't
have taught myself so I just wondered if
you could say how some people are
actually like I actually have no real
idea about that I mean to be the the
interdict is present phenomenologically
has conscience and so when this
conscience emerge right and under what
conditions I don't know
more like this I've been trying to
figure this out I mean let's put it this
way I mean it's not illogical like Pat
answer would be we're sitting here
talking to each other it's always
already happened you know and there's
something to that I mean and maybe some
other kind of developmental disorder can
be sold but if you try to make sense
that I'm people all to hear with the
totality that if you try to make sense
of it it has the same structure as being
a time he goes through all these
seemingly independent prior conditions
or conditions of the living being and we
suddenly find ourselves you know in
houses putting our stuff away and stuff
and all these later and all of this is
supposed to have her preparing away from
the others but it turns out that it's
already pretty supposedly so I can't say
that that that's a developmental story
he has some side issues in that some
paragraphs that are sort of screened
about totality and infinity talking
about how this is the transcendental
philosophy trying to fly
issues for a given condition but he's
going to let the empirical instances do
the work whereas most of the time the
transcendental philosophy there we need
to categorize or something so that's a
key passage we're trying to figure out
why he uses this language that really
there's nothing sequential about it
because it's both like sort of question
about I'm not somewhat you take the
about me about 908 to be Heidegger maybe
it seems like that mouseling picture
there's sort of a triple-layer cage
that's the more you know there's like
the non normative freedom of the living
being which he calls some sort of
freedom freedom to satisfies your wants
and needs and the Nexus interdiction on
that freedom which is what you call
normativity
and then there's a third layer which is
like rationality yeah so first I wonder
like how we make sense of that picture
and what if anything you think is
something compelling about that way of
doing it I think that related them to
are you meeting conscience normative in
highly their businesses still seems like
they're all your account non normative
inclinations of data that can act as
course is for be taken up as reasons so
there seems to be like rather than but
like all of this is understood
environment for the sake of that already
in place we would be dark on excited on
what the picture is like that that is
thereby the separation between the size
my stylist living being and my
commitments as a spiritual being
I think acceleration can be made because
that capacity to for spiritual freedom
to use your language can break down that
is to say some people beings revert to
states in which they're no longer
capable being acting for the sake of a
dot sign then I don't want to get stupid
with you I would say no I don't think
right and mutants today you break down
that way you draw a line yeah and so at
that point whatever the living being has
in regard to causes and inclinations are
no longer in or vertically guided but
then this is sort of break down into
more states necessary for the combine to
get the call that breakdown and anxiety
is not break down or psychosis or
something else
the gaff s - I mean we did we talk about
things one after another we can
I think that well there's no drives and
inclinations and causes that enter into
our experience that are not taking up
normatively I would say and I think
that's the same 411 altitude though he
has an interview he identifies freedom
and it's the restraint on that freedom
that needs to be freedom is the freedom
to appropriate and remain the same in
the other in the world the living being
has that what it needs is an orientation
beyond the status of that is that we're
talking not here about the orbit of 'ti
the phenomenology of the origin of
reason we're talking about the origin of
the second person standpoint I have to
be talk about all this freed equal stuff
and so that's where the developmental
story from Xavier Ostend professor
Garhwal comes in in Darwin's book he's
he's saying well look I mean how can
what I mean the real challenge to this
is we want something more out of the
second person standpoint then for it to
be a merely psychologically necessary
you know state we want these reasons to
have
and we'll call the metaphysical
significance but they want to have to
have validity if it's only a
psychological state then they ultimately
don't don't have the kind of validity
that they claim and persons aren't what
they claim to be and so on and he has
some very interesting things to say
about how one might construct an
argument it sounded rather
transcendental you know as to why there
was some necessity to this game that
that rendered it more than optional or
illusory and I'm just suggesting another
but but in terms of how to explaining
this entering into the both habermas and
our wall take up you know the history of
moral consciousness so to speak return
to sociology developmental psychology
and and do that and I'm not saying
there's anything wrong with that
but I'm saying there's another kind of
question about because I would
ultimately say that the ability to do
developmental psychology and the history
of moral enlightenment depends on what
I'm talking about
but yeah the point is that the second
person standpoint is is not the same as
entering into the space of reasons
this difference of the second person
standpoint and kind of second
personalization I thought that someone
United showed that somehow I mean that's
weight one way into it some of this is
not mention of being caught in too long
to order there is not already of the
form of ebony claim to or another
plaintiff on yeah so we are already in
this kind of game miss Opoku the
reciprocal relation where we we have to
Authority and exchange reasons of this
all but but there's another way of being
called upon people yeah receivable
people some of the cost into this other
dimension then lastly maybe to also
entertain some kind of you're the second
person standpoint that Steve is
describing but there is there has a
richer dimension and in some sense I
also thought that it's important that
this kind of being caught in to load all
obviously somehow in excess of this kind
of contractual relation on the second
person right and always drags me beyond
this kind
I mean these exceeds the type of reasons
that there was one thing that I was
wondering oh yeah whether you think that
it somewhat exceeds this transgressors
the song gives us a certain energy that
points beyond this kind of yeah I mean
is what opens me out on to the demand
[Music]
for keeping so-so it's what enables the
second person standpoint when I'm in the
second person stamp but what is that
that's I mean I'm just I'm treating
others and the claims that can be valid
within standpoint are predicated on my
treating others and myself as
essentially interchangeable rationale
really nothing but rational beings there
are only some parts of our lives where
the relationship symmetry of that kind
are
I suppose depends on how far down you
think this is sort of moral symmetry of
those in every aspect of our lives
but I would say that all I need all I
really wanted to try to do was say that
it presupposes this other report address
which also goes beyond establishing the
rules for the second person standpoint
or establishing the conditions of
possibility of the second person
standpoint so I don't think I'm not sure
I am the crux of your questions that
help if I wanted to talk about how to
get it you know I kind of think of it
this way and if here I talk about how
you know there comes a point I mean you
learn all the stuff from people and you
know there's a lot of no no no and at
some point you know
at some point you know that that know is
is it away constitutive of you it
doesn't it's not some external command
that you then get the idea that you can
fight it the force seems to me and then
you can identify it I mean there's I'm
right there's no identifying the
aggressor you say well okay that's just
the voice of the super-ego parents but
then you've missed the point then you
really haven't taken it over
yeah still outside there you're still
trying to escape normative just
describing it I could be formally the
question about
this way that the structure that is
originally PU has seems that seems would
have a different different system
acquire different social function then
the second person step so if you think
about this type of first appear as an
evening this other title take about
systemic point then it's the conditional
possibility of it but at the same time
in the very social structure edit the
trades on intention with the kind of
sympathy that is in place then some of
the second dose assembler is enabled by
a symmetric second personal relation
that you don't want to see both as some
of God's command or something and it
still is it's an asymmetric appeared and
so this the second person step for all
the relies on a structure the different
sort it's impossible tension so in
essence I think this other structure
appeals remains in place kind of
challenges or pushes the boundaries of
this yeah other right is I think about
in terms of the dimension of the ideal
so that there's a certain I'm drawn to
brace
to take a stand on what I think I want
to do and that can't it can't be drawn I
mean this is what I mean by
responsibility as answerability by King
to stand in that way I'm beholden to
other people to give reasons about why I
think these things are the best so I
there's a tension between what is
actually bandied about as the structure
of the second person standpoint what I
it's possible tension but that tension
is just the argumentative situation
right it's I I can't just withdraw that
was sort of the point
I can't just withdraw from that
obligation to just buy my to justify
myself in terms of what I take to be
best so that tension is just what we
call
you've ministered at some point that
from the know no nose you eventually
reach in some sense the second person
perspective
know what I'm saying kind of thinking of
my parents what distinguishes for
instance this visit sunset this
experience of being ability to fulfill
my needs with respect to a human's
restrictions on me from the restrictions
that might have been imposed on me by
some very complex creature there's no
sense of a wall that simply does not
allow me to do something but it's also
complicated and gives me some patterns
of behavior that I wouldn't follow when
this images in some sense there are
scriptures and close by something
complicated but not human and there's
pictures imposed by the human being what
wise is the human being able to give me
this primordial experiences that
introduces me to this person's
perspective not this complicated
creature yeah well my point was in
moving from letting us to Heidegger that
it's arbitrary
you can't phenomenon of conscience
there's no way to identify the dresser
and the a dresser you can you say that's
the voices my parents or it's God or
it's something else
but it's your own introduction of your
own where is freedom but the unique
question is
you accuse it if you prefer that's the
point I want to say this let me know
that you've received that and so of
course you know that sort of constitutes
your own self as itself as a performer
being that's responsible and there may
be reasons why in various I mean what
would levy not say like why did he
identify the other human being as Viggo
other why do I have to do that well you
could say well the response to the other
in the neutral sense is answering are
offering reasons language because of the
way that introduct
the interdiction wherever it came from
the precise way in which a restriction
for you so why wouldn't I be not saying
is obviously the other human being well
because we only answer to other you know
you can also come say well you know it's
difference between Judaism Christianity
there's a lot of different things you
could say but if you wanted to try to to
try to the way I tried to make sense of
it is that we have to leave it open but
right now the only people we talk to
other people
so the language would be essential
languages it would be essential what
would be central Canada for instance in
the diary but again I did my answer to
myself without my wish
well I think that that what he is
weighted the language here doesn't mean
simply that I say something but I think
that my response to the call when he
calls taking over being Brown is a kind
of language because it takes those the
facting ground as he puts it and turns
it into justifying reasons and way
reasons are part of my bits I I mean I
owe them to others and and whether I
speak them out or not or consider them
as reasons I think that's
[Applause]
[Music]